-Elle était maquillée
comme une star de ciné.
Accoudée au jukebox.
Elle rêvait qu'elle posait
juste pour un bout d'essai,
à la Century Fox,
Elle semblait bien dans sa peau.
Ses yeux couleur menthe à l'eau
cherchaient du regard un spot
le dieu projecteur.
Et moi je n'en pouvais plus.
Bien sûr elle ne m'a pas vu.
Perdue dans sa mégalo.
Moi j'étais de trop.
Elle marchait comme un chat
qui m'éprise sa proie
en frôlant le flipper.
La chanson qui couvrait
tous les mots qu'elle mimait,
semblait briser son coeur.
Elle en faisait un peu trop
la fille aux yeux menthe à l'eau.
Hollywood est dans sa tête.
Toute seule elle répète.
Son entrée dans un studio.
Le décor couleur menthe à l'eau.
Perdue dans sa mégalo.
Moi je suis de trop.
...
Mais un type est entré.
Et le charme est tombé.
Arrêtant le flipper.
Ses yeux noirs ont lancé
de l'agressivité
sur le pauvre jukebox.
La fille aux yeux menthe à l'eau
a rangé sa mégalo
et s'est soumise aux yeux noirs,
couleurs de trottoir.
Et moi je n'en pouvais plus.
Elle n'en a jamais rien su.
Ma plus jolie des mythos,
couleur menthe à l'eau.
...
[Applaudissements.]